[Music]
honestly you say that what is the deal
with the mashimas throwing each other
off cliffs i feel like it's something
that's been done to a lot of important
things in history i'm pretty sure
they've thrown jewelry in volcanoes to
make sure they stop people i just feel
like they might like stuff like that and
tossing bodies in there and how could
you forget the the one ring it's just
saying bro and mordor look i'm just
saying they might be some really really
big fans
of volcanoes to the point where they
know that's how you get the job done
they want to deep fry it and then just
get it done with it i mean the volcano
only came into play twice there were
cliffs at the very beginning tekken 1
and tekken 2 were cliffs i just feel
like if ever ever a point of volcano
comes into play and we got beef with
each other that's the next level of beef
like if i say yo beat me at the volcano
you might as well notify the next to ken
you might have to avenge me because so
we're gonna have the next twt finals at
active volcano is that what you're
saying i ain't saying all of that let me
be the guy in the helicopter commentator
i don't want to be down on the field on
that one but i mean personally i think
that it's just that's what you do to get
the job done i mean if you had you know
a rodent problem just dump that bad boy
in the volcano get rid of it
lickety-split i honestly don't know why
they do that but i thought it was a
obviously for dramatic effect i mean it
worked i mean you would think you would
think
you tossed someone off a cliff you
tossed someone into a volcano they're
done right but obviously they're not
those guys keep coming back for more
question question
if you saw me throw somebody off a
volcano would you want beef with me
no exactly that's really all it is
that's a statement it's a statement you
got to make a point like bro they might
they might try to come back if i throw
somebody in the volcano they not trying
to mess with that
man i thought you were going to throw
rip into a volcano when we were in
thailand the way you were handling him i
was like oh he's about to pick him up
he's about to pick up and that would
have been the end of rip right there
think about it guys volcanoes
[Laughter]
[Music]
you